happy holidays holidays season's
greetings so let's start again
it's are you sure the mics on yes ok you
sure the cameras on yes ok cool
hey everyone look how adorable these are
look how they are all right I want a
parolee yeah
hello everyone happy Holidays to you and
yours this is film courage I've always
wanted to say that let's start with that
ok that sounds good I'm with that we
have a bit of a dilemma thank you it's
rolling is my hair ok I gotta have big
hair alright hey hi everyone it's always
better when you go first huh always he
knows what to say um hello we had some
some spite that both cider now we're
sitting down in front that's what's
crazy about that is I don't even drink
so we're putting this out to you our
listeners is there any oh did you want
to say something
I totally that's my bad you know and
we've and we just this one tank so I
like when you said sugar boom cookies
and I tried to trigger you and oh okay
all right all right
did you did you get a sip of something
you just you're just like more chill the
thing is is that they can't see my ears
no huh
so I want you to lean back so you look
like that too because they can't see my
ears here let me let me go back it can't
like it's not they don't like I see the
ears the whole time okay as long as they
see them initially you cut me back okay
you know or second thing - and - with
that there are four ways four and four
and with that we would like to know if a
couple things - and - if
you I'm thinking of Chuck Woolery
anybody see love connection with Chuck
Woolery film courage at gmail.com or at
film courage at face are non-stop with
that four and four you can contact us at
film courage at gmail or at film courage
on Twitter or the good ol Facebook or
WWF encourage calm there's no money says
WWE film courage at gmail.com yeah at
film Kurds on Twitter and Facebook
yeah or WW I know damn it oh film you
almost put HTTP it comes down to this
there's a lot of holiday partying and
I'm all ready what's going on right now
it's like something on the reel off the
the number of ways you can contact this
right and if it's if it's yourself oh
let's try to get off this it's not
because you just said one person to
recommend you didn't say like themselves
to my hair like oh yeah we're saying
with that too much okay with what's
great is what you don't see on screen is
that Karen is wearing um Santa socks and
you can't see it right now okay so we're
not oh so I'm not supposed to say that
all right we have a show coming up on
Sunday December 26 12:00 noon pacific
standard time it's kind of a hard slot
to fill it's the day after Christmas
work with me here David hold on hold on
let's get some banter going here okay
hey we got a genuine real for these
people we need to be real for the people
man rare Oh give radios up in here okay
they might be with their families they
might be on vacation they might be hung
over from too much eggnog they could be
climbing a mountain top on a spiritual
quest yeah we just don't know
yeah and I was like something I want to
do so yeah once we have the list did you
to see you said all that I
yeah okay that's pretty much it back I
like that yeah no we're you know let us
know if you want to come on film courage
anything else our that's it look at it